Vicki Vicki rich reefer mercy we drove I
was born in Culver City when I brought
in hospital
tell me buddy chocolate you grabbed it
both your parents only cook my mom soon
oh yeah
and how was he talking um it was okay
until my brother molested me at 12 yeah
older brother yeah and it was behind him
and his friend actually they did both
they both did something at me
they were playing spin the bottle I
don't know if you've heard of that no
and me I didn't know anything I was
young over you know I was always world
so my brother spins the bomb I guess his
friends spin the bottle and the bottle
lands on his friend so he tells his
friend to take me in the bathroom and
for me to suck his dick sorry I'm saying
that but and then it was my brother's
turn to get spend and it landed on him
the bottle and his friend home I dare
you to go in the bathroom and have sex
with her
that's just what he did
and it continued until maybe 1314
and I finally got I finally let it out
when I was 39 years old I let it out it
finally came out to the light when I was
about 35 about four years ago and I
don't have no relationship with him no
more because the truth came out and he's
in denial of it you never even talked
about it it's over 35 yeah I can't be at
all I kept it inside until then I didn't
tell anybody
no I told my mom before she died and my
thing is is that if if I was lying I
wouldn't remember partial things of what
happened and after this game was done
after that after he did what he did he
continued to do it we would go in the
closet he would tell me you can't tell
nobody the blankie we would use would be
green and things like that you don't
remember you don't if you're lying
you're not gonna remember none of that
it's always gonna affect you and me it
does and it actually affected my kids my
kids were molested by their father two
of them yeah and now one of them that
was molested she keeps running away and
now they can't blind her old 16 this
happen or this is the third time that I
know about the second time that I found
about was the police called me from
Fontana
and they told me have I seen my daughter
Sandra and I told him no they said
she's missing and I had already felt
that because my sister sending me a text
message about my daughter wanted to go
to her house and stay with her for a
couple days and um when my sister
responded to me about which she asked me
what's going on with Sandra and I said I
don't know I haven't been able to get in
contact with her she tells me yeah she
she instagrammed me and told me that she
wanted to come and stay for a couple
days and when I responded to her she
heard her her file was deleted
there was nothing our facebook is
deleted when my sister and messaged when
she facebooked me a message sending me
that message I knew from then something
was wrong when the police called me
after the police called me and they gave
me all the information my daughter
called me and told me that
they picked her up and they took her
home and my daughter was lying to me
and and again she did the same thing all
over again she did it the day before
they called me and then she did it again
the day that they called me and now
she's at it again my thing is is that me
I don't think my daughter's running away
just for nothing I mean I think my
daughter's running away for a reason
somebody's doing something to her and
she doesn't know what to do just like
her dad did just like we do yeah yeah
and they say that you know what when it
happens to it it how do you say that it
uh it goes on to the next generation
they say well if I was molested my kids
are mean something's gonna happen like
that to my kids yeah are you 16
yeah and my other daughter she's been in
trouble with the law behind what's
happened to her because she that's
everything she lets people get away with
doing things to her and it built up so
bad to work she almost didn't really
really Bible II she gave a girl
concussion because the girl wouldn't
leave her alone about things that were
going on with her that happened here
somehow and their school it got around
to what happened to Mike my girls and my
daughter she is sure she'll take as much
as she can
until she explodes and she exploded and
she got in trouble she had to be on
probation she you know they had a gig
they got kicked out of the school that
they were in your daughter's my family
was there yeah yeah their father was
deported he was he's not from Mary he's
Mexican and he was deported behind doing
this oh really
yeah me I'm a victim of domestic
violence physically mentally for 17 plus
years behind him you know he's done a
really lot of things and I'm not saying
I'm perfect you know it goes both ways
but he's threatened to kill me and my
kids he's I've even tried to commit
suicide to myself I could um I'm what
they call a cutter you know and I'm out
here on this trees I had everything
everything was good behind him and him
doing what he did which is lewd acts on
a child under the age of 14 we lost
everything I had a job I had everything
and now I can't even get help I can't
get help for sheltering for victims of
domestic violence for mental problems
and for counseling I called this place
to get to get help to get support and
everything and they returned my call
they told me they were gonna return my
call after after the holidays you think
they ever did
I've been trying to get help out here
and it's not easy it's not ten you're
living on the street yeah how are you
guys you know probably about four or
five years now but I don't do like what
everybody else is does I smoke weed yeah
but that's about it
you're doing hurt yeah that's not
I used to I'm 17 I was 17 plus years
clean I got sober and clean after what
happened to me I went to drugs what my
brother did to me I went to drugs I was
smoking crack I started smoking crack
when I was there around almost 13 and me
I stopped for 17 years and I stopped by
myself I did it oh cold turkey by myself
and no program I'm nothing I can't me I
can't be on the streets again and do
that because it's me
my kids because like I said I have to
get the help that I need
I was court-ordered because of what I
because I try to commit suicide to get
help get counseling and everything I
can't even you know what I get gr I
don't get cash I can't even afford to
buy my to take out my driver's license
because I don't get no cash well they
get food stamps so it's kind of hard on
me and if I don't have an ID nobody
wants to help you my IDs expired they
don't want to help you you know I
actually told my mom like maybe maybe
five months before she died about what
my brother did to me and me I was too
willing to take a lie detector test and
everything
and nothing was ever said I told him
that since he didn't since he was lying
and saying that I am that I'm a liar
I said I'll take a lie detector test
I'll go on this Pete Wilcox show if you
want me to and I'll tell you there and
you come out do you see the connection
between what happened to you you know
what happened to my kids yeah where you
are today where your kids are today yeah
do you think using any of that stuff
would have happened now if that hadn't
happened oh if it wouldn't happen to me
no I don't think it
Jason yeah a lot and being out here
changes my life too and I want to get
off the streets so bad but it's hard
it's hard cuz I go for help
I've called all I get is call shelters I
call him no key I don't get no answer
I go to places oh we can't help because
you don't have a job you don't have an
ID
what's wrong with using my social
security number that's my nephew sue you
know I know they don't expect that
anyway
in my try and my ID driver's license
can't be expired the only one is that
the one that I have right now is the
paper one and it's expired and they
don't was said that
yeah it is I'm not I'm not used to this
like me I would stay up for days because
I'm not used to sleeping in a tent I'm
not I probably slept in two tents this
is the second time that I slept it with
I mean it's because the reason why is
you don't know what can happen somebody
could do something some kind of somebody
robbed somebody and they can come out
and take it after you're out off it
through with that person really you have
heard stories I've heard people tell me
about how somebody got them for their
money and they put the they grab their
tent and they got a chain and they
dragged it with the people in the tent
you know things like that I've seen
things I've seen a man drive down this
block and a man who was hanging on the
outside of his car talking about give me
my lane
I've seen a lot of things and it's kind
of scary I'm not used to things like
that
yeah you know and if you're Dan
especially if you're not used to things
like this you know I mean living in
South Central it's bad but here's al
Centro in downtown LA they don't got
nothing on each other it's all sensors a
little bit better than this yeah yeah
Peru yeah thank you thank you so much
for talking to me you're welcome thank
you for you my story yeah with
everything and your kids too
thank you